foreign
Ty in here that Mexican OT
what's going on baby thank you so much
for having me it's a pleasure let's have
fun baby welcome sir yes sir thank you
so who's your favorite wrestler of all
time
um
man dude I'm gonna have to go to John
Cena Cena I would love to say uh Edgar
you know I mean Edgar Eddie Eddie
Guerrero you know Rip but I feel like it
was like because how old are you because
Eddie died like yeah I'm 24 I just
turned uh 24 right now so you probably
didn't really get to watch Eddie like
for real for real when he was like
popping popping nah not so much but like
I said just because of what he stands
for how he came out of the low rider all
that [__] yeah man I'm saying and he had
Texas Mexican that's really what it is
but you know what I'm saying and now
with the WWE Network you can catch up on
all that [__] right right bro the
[__] the video game I bought the
newest one and like they had like uh on
the story mode you can unlock characters
in their skins and [__] you can unlock
the Rey Mysterio costume uh I think it
was like 90
it was 90 something it was Halloween and
he had the all purple suit Halloween
havoc
yeah that's crazy [__] yeah that's
what's up you know you'll never be able
to unlock who Chris Benoit why because
he murdered his entire family in a
steroid rage damn and then killed
himself
that was our steroid Rage that's what
that was yeah holy [__] that makes that
[__] way crazy I thought he was just
depressed I'm sure it was a lot of that
he was on roids he had a ton of
concussions juice the [__] up that's
crazy murdered his whole family yeah no
that's that's insane but but also one of
the greatest wrestlers of all time yeah
but somehow he raced from the books
it's crazy you remember Sergeant
Slaughter of course yeah he was crazy I
feel like Sergeant Slaughter was like a
little racist yeah but I mean dog like
there's some of those old like wrestlers
I love Uncle Ruckus
do you like The Boondocks bro by far but
definitely top three for me wait I gotta
see I gotta blow your mind though thank
God for the white women
yo first of all Uncle Ruckus is one of
the best TV characters ever hey who do
you think would win in the fight
Charleston white Uncle Ruckus Uncle
Ruckus yeah thank you [__] okay bro
Uncle Ruckus was [__] fighting with
Huey and you know Huey [__] he knew
like what was it like [__] some crazy
[__] stink made a new too Stinkmeaner
died beat Satan up with that fighting
[__] and came back so hold on listen
hey America this is Uncle Michael and
even though he dressed and sound like a
donkey you are listening to the greatest
white man oh Lord he smelled like
furniture polish and lemon zest God
bless his white skin yeah leg calf I got
a [__] Uncle Ruckus drop that's
[__] hard dog
that's odd do you remember uh you
remember Clayton Bixby of course Dave
Chappelle Dave Chappelle's that guy if
you want to see my face and then
everyone and then the guy's head
explodes
and then he divorced his own wife
because she was an n-word lover yeah oh
my God such a great we want to see her
face Clayton Bixby come on Clayton show
us your face yeah
hey shout out Dave Chappelle man he was
over there [__] with my dog Ralph
Barbosa that [__] was cool to see you
got uh Ralph Barbosa doing the skits
with you on your album yes sir we
actually have some uh some like you know
some anime to it too ah it's an
animation is that started to roll out
uh I don't know but I know where it's
coming I don't you know yeah it's
definitely gonna be a part of the
project I just don't know
I don't think we have a drop day for it
maybe yeah so your album has like a a
very continuous theme throughout it
which is dope because I feel like a lot
of artists these days don't use skits
like when I was growing up skits were
like important parts of albums yeah
Eminem did them all Eminem Kanye like
[__] big pun like skits were the [__]
so you like like for you is it like
important to make sure you kind of you
know had a full theme throughout the
project I actually wasn't even I
wouldn't even thinking those kids I was
so worried about just making good music
My Boy Johnny was the one that was like
cause like me I'm not the type of person
where like I know albums and right and
songs and [__] like I'm the type of
person like if it's here and I hear it
and I know it I know it I don't know the
name of it right you know what I'm
saying so that's how I am so like I
wasn't even thinking of that because I
didn't know that that was I didn't
understand that that was laid out in
projects you know what I'm saying so
when he told me like yeah you know the
man all the all these projects I have it
you know it just made sense I was like
damn I want to do that and then uh you
know as soon as Ralph got that he had a
[__] notepad full of you know all
these notes and you know we just went
crazy from there
um you have a song on your album is it
called briannon Brienne Brianna Brianna
it's kind of like uh your version of
like Eminem's cam a little bit you think
so how how much of a true story is we
both got like women issues yeah I was
going to say like uh that's a pretty
crazy record yeah you've heard it yeah I
listened to the whole album oh Pride
that's hard that's hard as [__] yeah
yeah I got I got all the way to like the
last two records I didn't hear I didn't
hear the uh I think was it Cowboy murder
or some [__] or Cowboy killer cowboy in
New York oh Cowboy killer yeah I didn't
get to that the last two from there yeah
that's okay I think the last record I
heard was the cowboy in New York right
yeah cowboy in New York was definitely
fun I uh that one was crazy to do